had sergeants in the army where they  were just not good leaders you know what  the army would do they'd come up to you  if you're less than 15 years they didn't  want you to retire with 20 years because  they didn't want to pay you for the rest  of your life they'd come and they would  say hey man we'll give you 30 000 for  you to leave today  flat out they'd come and say we'll give  you 20 you know how many people would  take it a lot of them because army's  sitting there saying we're wasting our  time with this person that's not going  to be a leader here's 15 grand leave  here's 30 grand leave i think many of  these districts need to go to the bad  teachers and say here's 30 000 leave you  don't need to do this anymore so